JIM LECINSKI: Well, good
Friday afternoon, everyone,
and welcome to another exciting
edition of Authors at Google.
We're originating today from
our wonderful Google Chicago
office.
[APPLAUSE]
Round of applause.
I will be your presumptive
moderator for the day using
the zeitgeist word of the day.
I'm Jim Lecisnki,
and our guest today
is with us, Chris Anderson.
Chris is the curator
of the TED conference
and has been since
2002, following
a long and successful career
in the publishing industry.
We'll talk a little
bit about that today.
Chris has developed TED
into a global platform
for identifying
and disseminating
ideas worth spreading.
Welcome, Chris.
[APPLAUSE]
So great to have you with us.
I wonder if maybe we
could get started,
if you'd tell us a little
bit about your background.
I mentioned the publishing.
How does a philosophy
major and publisher
come to lead and transform
one of the world's
great digital brands?
CHRIS ANDERSON: Definitely
a long, twisting journey.
I was a journalist
originally, actually,
when I first came
out of university,
and I made the mistake of buying
one of the early computers.
It was like a Tandy TRSAT clone.
And I was awed by this thing.
I kind of completely
fell in love with it,
and to cut a long story
short, a few years later,
I found myself working at one
of the early home computer
magazines, and I loved that.
And then I decided,
this isn't so hard.
Let's publish one.
So I started a company,
published a magazine.
Bizarrely, it worked, and
then this thing took off.
And so the publishing
part was just
building lots and lots of these
nichey hobbyist magazines that
were deeply boring to everyone,
except the people they
were targeted at, who
kind of loved them.
And so we had this philosophy.
Our complete logo was
actually, "Media with passion."
And that's always been my
mantra as an entrepreneur
is look for the passion.
If you can find something
that people are really
passionate about,
that's your clue
that there's something
there, that this is kind
of the proxy for potential.
And so when I first came to
TED in 1998, TED was back then,
it was actually started in '84.
Nothing on the
internet, of course.
It was an annual conference.
That was it.
And I went there in '98.
It was bringing together
Technology, Entertainment,
Design, TED, and I
fell in love with it.
I thought, I've come home.
And what I saw was this passion.
People were so
passionate about it.
It was like, this is my
best week of the year.
And I thought, why is this
your best week of the year?
But that was the clue.
And so when there was a chance
to buy TED from its founder--
he was 65-- and I leapt at it.
And so that happened in 2001,
and the journey since then
has been a wild
journey of its own.
But that's how I got there.
JIM LECINSKI: Great.
And we'll talk about
that journey since then.
In some sense, it's
been said that it
was the power of what was
then new media back in 2006,
online video in particular,
that really gave TED its boost.
Would you say that's the case?
CHRIS ANDERSON: That's
absolutely the case.
When I bought it, I bought
it with a nonprofit,
a foundation I had.
And so the intention
was always, it
felt like there was
all this inspiration.
It was supposed to be for
the public good somehow,
but how could you
let out the knowledge
that was at this private
conference to the world?
And our first attempt
to do that was on TV,
and TV wasn't interested.
These are lectures.
They're lectures.
They're kind of boring.
Lectures are boring.
Now I didn't actually
listen to them,
because they weren't boring.
But they weren't interested.
And so yeah.
So when this weird technology
called online video
with its shaky little kittens
and all these other things
happening came along,
we thought, wait a sec.
Maybe we could,
as an experiment,
put some TED Talks up.
Probably won't work.
They're too long
for the internet,
and you're not going
to be there live.
It's on video.
To our amazement, these
things went viral,
and so that was
the moment, 2006,
when we decided we had
to flip TED on its head.
We're no longer
just a conference.
We're a media organization
devoted to sharing ideas.
JIM LECINSKI: And so let's
build on that a little bit.
You described what TED stands
for, T-E-D, but how would you
talk about its
meaning, its purpose?
What does the brand stand for?
CHRIS ANDERSON: It stands
for the bringing together
of knowledge in ways that
people can understand.
The world's really complicated,
and most of the time,
we go deep.
You have to know something well
to have a chance of succeeding.
You dig deep.
You learn your speciality well.
And that's how most
things operate.
That's how most
conferences operate,
most university
courses, whatever.
That's what you have to do.
But there's a place for
context to actually understand
the world we're in.
You need to go
broader than that.
And actually, lots
of other things
happen when you bring together
knowledge from different areas.
You get the catalyzing
of new ideas.
You get the possibility
of collaboration,
and so I think that's
what hit me suddenly
was why Ted had a role to play.
There's just not
much of that happens.
And so if you can persuade
people to come together
from these different fields
and explain something
they're passionate about
in ways that other people
can actually understand,
that, I think, that definitely
over a few days, for example,
that had the effect of selling
these spots in your brain.
And you just thought
of stuff that you
hadn't thought of before.
And so that's what
it stands for.
JIM LECINSKI: We'll
come back and chat
a little bit in a
second about the power
of how those talks are built
on understandable ideas.
But I want to pursue--
you mentioned the word
collaboration.
Most of our audiences
has not had the pleasure
of actually attending the
conference when they were
in Long Beach or now
back in Vancouver,
so could you maybe paint a
little picture about not just
the speakers on
the stage that we
can see by watching
the video, but it's
a full four-day collaboration
event with the dinners.
And can you maybe
paint picture of what
happens during that week?
CHRIS ANDERSON: Sure.
So yeah, it's four
and 1/2-ish days.
There are basically 12
main sessions of TED.
Each session is an
hour and 45 minutes,
and it's five to six speakers,
plus other little performances
and things thrown in there.
So it's quite fast-moving.
What's unusual about TED is that
everyone sees every speaker.
It's one track.
And that doesn't usually happen,
but it is the whole point of it
is you are supposed to be
exposed to stuff you had
no idea you were interested in.
And it's become a truism at
TED that the session that you
think is going to be most boring
is the one that blows you away.
And so amazingly,
people do commit
to coming to each
session, and that
means that you can have a shared
conversation in the corridors
after.
And the collaboration is not
really something we stage.
It just happens that the
combination of that exposure
to these different
speakers and ideas,
it sort of sparks
things in people,
and weird projects
emerge out of it.
JIM LECINSKI: Yeah.
Now is it the case-- I had heard
that you discourage or don't
allow digital devices or
live tweeting or cameras
or these kind of
things in the room?
Is that the case?
CHRIS ANDERSON:
That is the case.
Apart from the back
two rows, where
people can tweet if they want
to, or in the simulcast spaces.
But in the main theater, we say
no, because all of life right
now is this attention war,
and talks are weird things.
They often take
a while to build.
To share a really big idea or
something that really matters,
you sometimes have
to build context.
You have to go through,
gosh, 90 seconds, where
it's a little bit challenging
or boring for a minute.
If people-- because I've
just got to check my email,
just for this moment.
They miss a couple of key
context things, they're gone.
And then the talk never lands.
And once more, the
five people behind them
are sort of annoyed, and it's
sending a signal that this
isn't that interesting.
So everyone else decides
it's not that interesting.
You are, right now, you
are a super organism.
You're all actually,
although you're not
fully conscious of it, you're
feeding off each other.
You take cues from each other.
And that's what happens
in a lot of things.
So we try to have a
different contract
from the normal contract.
Audience, you're actually going
to give your full attention
to this speaker for 18 minutes.
Speaker, you're going to work
bloody hard for several months
to produce the talk of your life
and make it worth their while.
And that's the deal.
JIM LECINSKI: You
know I actually
asked that question as
just a not-so-subtle hint
to our audience today.
CHRIS ANDERSON: I'm
actually stunned,
because I thought coming
to Google, of all places,
you guys would all be
coding and whatever.
You're all so brilliant,
you can multitask your way
through this.
No problem.
JIM LECINSKI: There you go.
So maybe tell us a little
bit about the simple question
of who gets to do a TED talk.
How do you decide?
CHRIS ANDERSON: In
principle, it's simple.
It's someone who's doing amazing
work that other people need
to know about, and
the rest is detail.
And so it's hard to decide
who those people are.
We get 10,000 suggestions a year
from people around the world.
We have a curation team.
For a conference,
we're trying to weave
a sort of mix of people
together around a theme.
This year's theme was dream
as in big, bold dreams.
But there's no
algorithm to it yet.
Please don't invent
one just yet,
or we'll be out of business.
It's a sort of-- because
we want, with the program,
to-- and I think a lot of
events fail to do this.
We want to poke at
every different part
of people's minds.
It can't just be about something
analytical or storytelling,
what have you.
There are different
parts of minds
engaged when you start
to go to the aesthetic
or to someone's inspiring
story, or to here's
a really complex scientific
issue that we're tackling in.
There's energy that
comes from that,
and so it's not
just who you bring.
It's then trying to sequence
them in a way that will work.
JIM LECINSKI: I
heard you once say
that-- I don't know if it's a
filter or a screen how you put
it-- but one
consideration that you
look at in deciding on
a speaker is who would
benefit from hearing this idea.
Is it just you?
Is it just your team?
Is it just your organization?
Or--
CHRIS ANDERSON: Right.
So that is actually--
I would say
that is the number one
advice to a speaker,
and it's the core thing
that's in the book.
It's so tempting as a
speaker, you think, hey,
I've got an opportunity.
So I'm going to use it.
I'm going to promote my
organization, my cause,
and in the process, I'm
going to take the chance
to be a little bit of a
rock star, because I can.
And that's the trap that
so many people fall into,
and it's very counterproductive,
because it actually shuts down
the audience.
If you can do it the
other way around,
if you can make
clear from the start
that your purpose in being on
stage is to give something,
is to give people a gift, a
gift of something that you know,
and that if they knew, it would
make a difference to them.
I mean our lives are built
around our worldviews.
Different knowledge
means a different life.
It means doing things
differently maybe years
into the future.
So come with a gift,
and I think if we
don't see that in a speaker,
if we smell for a minute
that they're in it for
self-promotional purposes
primarily, not interested.
JIM LECINSKI: Right.
And that's good advice not just
on stage at your conference,
in general, I suppose.
CHRIS ANDERSON: I
think in general.
I think absolutely in general.
Even frankly, even if you
are trying to sell something,
the best salespeople don't
come on and say, hey,
here's what I got.
They say, what are
you passionate about?
What are you thinking about?
What do you need?
What are you curious about?
How can I help?
So absolutely.
Every speaker should be
thinking about the audience
and what they can offer that
could be of interest and use.
JIM LECINSKI: Now in terms of
speaking delivery and speaking
ability, you've
described yourself,
and I think greatly
underselling your powers,
as not a natural
charismatic speaker.
In some senses,
your predecessor was
a charismatic, outgoing person.
But you've had this
awesome ringside seat
for the past dozen or so or more
years watching great speakers.
So what have you observed about
the perennial debate of you're
a natural at it or not, or
you can learn it or not?
Some people can only get so
far at being a good speaker.
What's your point on I
guess nature and nurture?
CHRIS ANDERSON: I
mean, I'm convinced
that the only thing that you
need to give a great talk
is something worth saying.
You need knowledge.
You need to have done some work
that deserves a wider airing.
The rest can be taught.
Honestly, it can be taught,
because the last thing you want
is for everyone to learn some
sort of style of speaking.
We don't want to think of
speaking as a performance.
There definitely
are some people who
are natural performers
and who can in the moment
sort of smoothly pluck
beautiful, elegant phrases out
of nowhere and pass them on.
So not everyone
probably can do that.
But that's a good thing.
We don't want
everyone to do that.
It would get
exhausting, honestly.
What you want is a variety
of different people,
different skills, different
standpoints, different speaking
styles.
What you want is authenticity.
You want people who
care about something.
And even if they half stammer
their way through a talk,
if you're learning
something, that is fantastic.
So I just feel
passionately about this
that it's a tragedy that there
are so many people out there
in the world, and I
bet there are even
people here in this
world-leading company, who
feel under-confident when
it comes to public speaking,
despite having something really
valuable to share, something
that if the rest of the
world knew, rest of the world
would like it.
And so we've got
to get over that.
JIM LECINSKI: Yeah.
So maybe if you tell us a little
bit about two people who've, I
guess, fit both of those
profiles or archetypes
that you just outlined.
Maybe Sir Ken Robinson
as a natural, a gifted,
one of those who can
pluck things out,
and maybe someone who's a little
more hesitant like a Monica
Lewinsky.
Maybe if you could just
tell us a little bit
about those two examples
to illustrate your point.
CHRIS ANDERSON: Sure.
I mean Sir Ken Robinson
came to TED in 2006.
I think he'd already
been voted Europe's Best
Speaker or something like that.
I was a little
suspicious of him,
because I thought
if he's that good,
what are we going to get here?
But he kind of shuffled
onto the stage and said,
you know, it's been
great, hasn't it?
I've been blown away.
In fact, I'm leaving.
And people sort of tittered
and giggled, and then
over the next 10
minutes, they just
didn't stop laughing, because
he just brilliantly told story
after story about kids.
And we all wanted
it to go on forever.
And having won all
that affection,
he was able to give us this very
inspiring story and argument
that creativity is completely
under-taught in schools,
undernourished.
And that resonated with
so many people so deeply.
And so that was 2006, and
it was told to 800 people.
And now 800 people
every hour watch
that talk online all
these years later,
and he's up to 38 million
or whatever it is.
Monica Lewinsky was terrified,
for obvious reasons,
coming to TED.
She'd stayed fairly invisible
for the best part of a decade.
And she felt passionate
about certain things,
about this issue
of cyberbullying.
But it took a lot of courage
for her to come and raise
her voice, and naturally,
coming into the conference,
she thought, gosh, what if
this is a big public stage?
I'm on video.
What if I'm humiliated again?
It was really hard for her.
I think she almost pulled
out a couple of times.
But what held her there was
she wrote on her script,
this matters.
And returning to sort of giving
this in the service of an idea
made a big difference.
She did a few smart
things physically
in terms of exercises,
breathing, whatever
before coming on stage.
And in her talk,
she structured it
cleverly so that
up front, she had
a very disarming personal
story right in the first minute
or two that had
everyone laughing.
And at that moment, she
told me she just relaxed
and knew that she had it.
So that talk was extraordinary.
That's been seen by
eight million people now,
and it really changed how a
lot of people thought of her
and how a lot of people
thought about this issue.
So I'd definitely say that
if she can overcome her fear,
anyone here who is
fearful of speaking could.
JIM LECINSKI: So you talk
about some of those conventions
that she used.
She also had some
great sticky phrases.
I remember one that hangs
with me is she called herself,
I think, patient zero
of cyberbullying.
So that brings up the
natural question of,
do you coach these speakers?
Do you write the scripts?
Do you edit the scripts?
Do you review them?
Or even are there scripts?
Or is it all improvised?
CHRIS ANDERSON: So it's
different in every case.
In the majority of
cases, there are scripts.
And we certainly don't write
them in the first place.
We invite a draft.
If we don't think
that it's quite there,
we may suggest some changes,
usually broadly, occasionally
line by line.
I mean, the hardest
thing for speakers
is actually to adjust
the scope of the talk
to fit 18 minutes or so.
Like people say, I'm
coming to give a big talk.
There are so many things
in my life I'm so proud of
and I want to share
with this group.
You want to jam them
all in somehow or other.
And that means that everything
gets dealt with surface level.
Overjammed equals
underexplained.
So the hardest thing
is the discipline
of cutting it out, cutting it
out, focusing on the one idea
that you're most
passionate about
and, therefore, giving yourself
time to unpack it properly,
to set up the context.
Why does this matter?
Why do I care about it?
Why should you care about it?
How has this been
tackled historically?
Why didn't that work?
What could work now?
Here's an example of
why that could work now.
Here's why it matters.
What are we going
to do with this?
All those things are what make
the idea vivid and actionable,
and so that's the hardest
piece is people just come
in with too much usually.
And we say to them, maybe
focus on this one thing.
JIM LECINSKI: I mean this is
the famous, if I had had time,
I would have written
you a shorter letter.
CHRIS ANDERSON: Exactly.
Exactly.
JIM LECINSKI: Exactly.
So in terms of
presentation styles,
I'm going to give you
two sort of poles.
Of course, there's many
shades of gray in between,
but there are the
speakers, I imagine,
who come in with a full script,
everything written, practiced
and timed, fully memorized
to 17 minutes and 59 seconds.
And it's recall,
push the button,
and all thousand words come out.
And there are
probably others who
come in with a series of
stories or bullet points
or sketches that
they kind of know
they want to cover
and want to leave room
for some spontaneity.
Do you see both?
Do you encourage both?
Can both work?
CHRIS ANDERSON: We see both.
We encourage both.
And both can work.
JIM LECINSKI: Next question.
CHRIS ANDERSON: The trap
is going in the middle,
in between the two.
So the type of talk that I
think we try and discourage
is the I'm planning
to memorize this,
but I'm still a
little bit stressed,
and I'm not quite there.
And the audience can hear that.
If you start giving your talk,
and then your eyes sort of roll
up a bit, and then,
oh, let me just
start that paragraph again.
And suddenly, people have
this sickening feeling-- oh,
my goodness.
He's reciting.
And the life, in a way, goes
out of it, because what you want
is this live human moment.
We're here, and you're smiling
at me, and now it's lovely.
You know, like I feel this
chemistry, this excitement.
This happens live,
and people want
to decode the I'm looking
at a live human mind,
and I'm making a
judgment right now.
And it's hard for you, because
you're looking at my shoulder
here, but I'm making a
judgment right now about
whether you can trust me.
It's hard to do that if you
think someone's reciting.
You actually can't.
So if you're in that mode,
here's what you have to do.
You don't tear it up
and go back to notes.
You double down
on your rehearsal,
and you own the talk.
You make it part of you so
that when you're in the room,
it's not at all a problem
to remember what you say.
You know what's coming next.
It's right there.
And you can focus
again on the meaning
and on wanting to connect with
you, because actually, now
that I think of it, this
particular idea is right
for you right now,
and speakers can
get to the point of doing that.
And I think probably the
majority of TED talks
are memorized.
A small number of them do
sound a little bit robotic,
and people push
back against that.
Most of them, you really
feel the person's passion,
and it's thrilling.
The danger of going the other
way is that you can ramble.
You can go over.
You can miss out some of the key
things that you wanted to say,
or you can miss the chance
to really use the best
language to say something.
You want to really
clearly explain something.
On the other hand, it
can be live and fresh,
and some people really
can do that very well.
What I'd say to someone
who was planning
to speak from bullet points is
it's still worth rehearsing it.
Rehearse it three
or four times, even
if it's just in your bedroom
with a cell phone there
recording.
You'll find out the
awkward moments in it,
and it'll change, and
you'll move from awkwardness
to owning the talk.
So either way, rehearse, and
get to the point, where you feel
like you really know the talk.
You feel like you just know it.
And then you can focus on
meaning and connection.
JIM LECINSKI: So let's get into
the book a little bit more.
I mean, this is some of the
content in the excellent book
that you've released.
You said that the goal
of every TED speaker
is to plant the seed
of a powerful idea.
CHRIS ANDERSON: Yes.
JIM LECINSKI: And
the book starts
to unpack ways to do that.
Let's, I guess, tackle the first
elephant or monkey here, which
is, is there a formula
to plant that seed?
CHRIS ANDERSON: No,
there's no formula.
I think the first thing
to note is that it's
a miracle that you can do it.
If you think, what is an idea?
If you could take
the idea, democracy
is fragile, if you could
color code that in your brain
and look at what
actually encodes
that in the human brain,
I would guess it involves
literally millions of neurons.
It's a fantastically
complicated pattern.
Yet somehow in an 18-minute
talk or less, a speaker
can transfer that entire pattern
into everyone else's minds.
It seems like an
impossible thing.
The only way it
happens, it can do it,
is because we share language.
So you're building this
pattern out of elements that
already exist in the minds.
What you're trying to
is to put them together.
But to do that, you
have to be incredibly
disciplined about remembering
that it's their language,
it's their concepts that you're
building from, not yours.
So your jargon, your
assumptions, that's what
can kill an
explanation stone dead.
And there's this cognitive bug
called the Curse of Knowledge,
which pretty much
everyone suffers from
and which is the tendency
to forget what it's like
not to know something.
You guys here, you
live in a world
where it's natural to talk
about algorithms and coding
and whatever.
You have a conversation
with people somewhere else,
and you suddenly wonder why
their eyes are glazing over.
It's actually not because
you're a boring person.
It's because you
missed out something
like they didn't understand
why this mattered
or what the context was.
And we do this all the time.
And so as a speaker, try
your talk out on someone
who isn't in your
normal circle, but who
might be like the
people in the audience.
See if they get it.
You kind of have to do that.
JIM LECINSKI: Yeah.
And so you've
talked a little bit
about how using
familiar concepts,
metaphors as a bridge to
get a complex topic across
can be effective.
CHRIS ANDERSON: Right.
So I think of a metaphor
as kind of like a template.
You've got these different
elements or ideas
in someone's mind,
and a metaphor
shows how they connect
together in a shape that's
familiar so that you get it.
So Jennifer Khan,
a science writer,
was trying to explain CRISPR
to us at the last TED.
And we've had several
scientists try and explain it,
and they got all
terribly complicated
and all this sort of complex
science of DNA and so forth.
She said, no, look, it's like a
word processor for the genome.
You can use CRISPR
to cut and paste
any gene to any part that you
want or, indeed, any letter.
And we go, wow, a word
processor for the genome.
I get it.
So metaphors are
really powerful,
and examples are
powerful as well
to make sure that you're
cementing in the knowledge.
Oh, so this is what I mean.
JIM LECINSKI: One of the
other conventions or devices
that you talk about in the
book is getting personal.
You mention Monica
Lewinsky opened her talk
with a personal story.
What's been your
experience or your advice
on using personal anecdotes
or personal experience?
Because often the advice
is speakers will come up
and say, I, I, I, me, me,
me turns off the audience.
CHRIS ANDERSON:
Yes, if you think
that the speaker is saying
it's all about me, that
is a turn off.
But I think there is a case
to try to diffuse skepticism
and mistrust.
If you think about it,
if this agenda of trying
to build an idea
in someone's mind,
you're doing something
very intimate there.
People are skeptical
about letting
a stranger come and poke
around inside their brain
without permission.
And so first of all, there's a
process of learning to trust,
of saying, do I
trust this person?
Do I like this person?
Do I want to open
up to this person?
And you need that opening
up to happen if explanation
is successfully to happen.
You can't push
knowledge into a brain.
It has to be pulled in.
JIM LECINSKI: And
so the personal
is the way to build that trust.
CHRIS ANDERSON: Right.
So I'd say it's not so
necessarily personal.
It's not saying, let me
tell you all about me.
It's more saying
in a personal way,
why this matters
but just showing it
in sort of an informal
way, rather than starting
at a conceptual level.
It's like saying, hey, we're
going to go on a journey
together.
This is where I'd like to go.
And by the way, it's
going to be fun.
Here's why you
should come with me.
And just trying to
convince people of that.
JIM LECINSKI: I want
to remind our audience
in a few minutes we'll be taking
questions at the microphones
here, so have your questions
ready in a couple of minutes.
One of the concepts that
really resonated powerfully
with me in the book is this
notion of the through line.
I wonder if you'd explain
that for our audience.
CHRIS ANDERSON: So if it's
right that a talk should
be about building an
idea in people's minds,
then everything in the talk
needs to connect to that idea.
You think of it as
your through line.
And so things that aren't
part of that get cut out,
but then everything
else connects to that.
When you think about
what's happening in a talk,
you're taking this very complex
three-dimensional object
of an idea, and you're
trying to transfer that.
And your means to do it is
a one-dimensional stream
of words.
So it's inherently hard,
and what you have to do,
therefore, is to thread
those words in a way
where it's clear how
each part relates.
So if you're going to
give a counter-example,
that needs to be clear that
that's what you're doing.
If you're giving some
historical context,
you need to show that
that's what it is.
If it's an anecdote, people
need to get a sense of how this
relates to what's happening.
Otherwise, again, it's like I
like the sound of your voice,
and this kind of
makes sense, but I'm
really not sure exactly
where you're going
and how these
pieces fit together.
And a lot of talks
feel like that.
They feel the pieces are there,
but it doesn't quite land.
JIM LECINSKI: Yeah.
In the book, you also talk
about a powerful speaking device
is to uncover and
explore a disconnect
or a seeming disconnect
in a common world view.
CHRIS ANDERSON: Yes.
Persuasion-- to persuade
someone of something,
you first have to show them
that what they believe right now
doesn't really make sense.
Like before you can blow
up someone's worldview,
you need to just
tease it out a bit.
So do you really
want to believe this?
How is that
consistent with this?
And so it's this wonderful
feature of some talks.
In a sort of teasing, friendly,
but in a powerful way,
just reveal that this
view has got to be absurd,
and that stokes curiosity.
And there's this concept
of the knowledge gap.
Once you are aware of this
knowledge gap in your mind,
you instinctively
just want to close it.
And curiosity says,
more, more, more.
Help me figure this out.
I don't like this.
JIM LECINSKI: Yeah.
In addition to the
talks themselves,
you've done a wonderful
job of extending the brand.
We've talked about putting those
talks and those videos online,
certainly the book that
we're talking about today.
But there's TED X, TED Ed,
some of these other brand
and line extensions.
I wondered if you would just
maybe talk about some of those
and how you see
those fitting in.
CHRIS ANDERSON: Having seen
the success of just giving away
the content, we
became a bit obsessed
with giving things
away and the power
of that in the connected age.
And so we thought, what
if we gave away our brand?
It doesn't seem like that
bright an idea at first glance,
so we added an X to TED
and said the X stands
for self-organized.
And if you would like to do
a TED-like event somewhere
in the world, we'll give
you a license to do it.
It's over to you.
And amazingly, there's
3,000 of these now a year.
So there's nine every day or so.
And obviously, we
couldn't do this.
Like I've got 15
people in New York,
who are overseeing
3,000 events a year,
and it's because of
the power of TED X.
So these events go from filling
out the Sydney Opera House
to an event in a jail or
TED X Baghdad or whatever.
Absolutely.
And we just love seeing
what happens there.
There's about-- YouTube,
thank you very much--
is the main distribution
vehicle for these.
There's more than 60,000 talks
on there, and many of them
are getting a lot
of views, so that's
been a thrilling experiment.
And then TED Ed is just our
reaching out to the brand
to a youth audience.
And instead of talks on a
stage, we're saying teachers,
let's have your best lesson.
Five or six minutes
to spark curiosity.
Thanks to Google,
knowledge is no longer
a problem in the world.
Everyone has access to
all the world's knowledge.
For some reason,
educators haven't quite
come to terms with this yet,
and we still think of education
as trying to jam knowledge
into a brain, to fill it up.
It should all be about nurturing
the right kind of curiosity
and the right way to ask
questions, the right way
to bring in the right knowledge.
So these are
curiosity-sparking videos,
and they're animated, but
from a teacher's best words.
And so we have the thrill
of a great teacher,
who during their whole career,
has reached 5,000 kids, at most
or whatever.
And suddenly in the first
hour of their talking online,
they've reached 50,000 kids.
And it's so thrilling for
them, and it's fun to see.
JIM LECINSKI: And
education and learning
has been long part
of, I would suggest,
one of the core tenets
or essences of TED.
I mean, obviously,
since the beginning,
but maybe perhaps,
Sal Khan, Salman Khan,
was one of the most preeminent
that came and talked
about education.
I wonder if you'd maybe share
some of your experiences
with him and what he's done.
CHRIS ANDERSON: I mean,
Sal Khan, in my opinion,
he's a true global hero.
I mean, for a hedge fund
manager to give over his life
to educating first his
cousin, his nephews,
and then the world, I mean,
it's really incredible
that one person could do that.
And he's starting with
just the power of video,
and then adding in
this idea of mastery
so that people can
learn at their own pace.
That's the real
power of video is
that it makes no sense
to force a bunch of kids
to learn at the same speed.
They're all different.
Video allows them to
decouple from time
and find their own rhythm.
And that allows people who you'd
never expect to master topics
in their own timing.
So it's incredible.
And he gave a very
inspiring talk at TED.
And by the way, he's got
the best single quote
in the book, which is when you
give a talk, just be yourself.
Like if you're a creative
person, be a creative person.
If you're a humorous person,
be a humorous person.
If you're an egoful person,
however, leave that aside.
JIM LECINSKI:
That's good advice.
And in a sense, what
started on your stage
there has been a
revolution in learning.
There are more than a
few school districts
who have so-called
flipped the classroom,
and the homework is watching Sal
Khan to absorb the information.
And then the class
itself is the practice,
as opposed to what
we all learned
was you learn during the day and
go home and practice at night.
So that has to be
very gratifying,
the kind of thing when you talk
about ideas worth spreading.
CHRIS ANDERSON: Yeah.
And I think that
is hugely powerful.
I think it's still
early days, and there's
lots of versions of
that being explored,
but I think it's very exciting.
JIM LECINSKI: Yeah.
Has there been any topic area
that you would very much wish
to have explored throughout
the TED process or on stage,
but you haven't just found the
quite right speaker, or maybe
an area that you've
thought about diving into,
but haven't been comfortable
bringing to the stage?
CHRIS ANDERSON:
Yeah, there are lots.
JIM LECINSKI: Any you'd
like to share with us?
CHRIS ANDERSON: Well,
just being personal
as the sort of
philosophical geek, who
used to lie on the floor
of his student room
trying to understand the world
and failing, consciousness.
Who the hell are we?
It doesn't make any sense.
I mean by all sort of scientific
definitions of consciousness
that you get to a certain
level of complexity
in decision making, Google
itself is conscious right now.
Maybe it is.
We don't know.
But what is it?
Who are we?
These are very
difficult questions,
and we've had a few speakers in.
But I would love more of that.
But that's a little selfish.
I mean, politics is hard, right?
In many ways, TED is sort of
this escape from the ranting
that we hear 24/7 on
cable, but there's
something about certain
topics that force people
into a tribal mode.
And it's very distressing
when we stop reasoning
with each other
and sharing ideas
and start shouting at each other
and just staking out positions.
And so we don't have traditional
political-type talks.
I would love to find more people
who can frame ways to bridge
and frame different ways
of looking at politics.
And so we're constantly
on the lookout for that,
but it's hard.
That's hard to do.
JIM LECINSKI: Let's
invite our audience
to come up to the microphones
and ask some questions,
and as they do that, you
mentioned scientific.
You know, there
are quite a lot of,
as you used the
example here today,
there are quite a lot of
heavy-duty scientific topics.
But then there's a lot of sort
of different points of view.
We can pick global warming.
Is it, isn't it these
kinds of things?
Do you have a
scientific body that
reviews the sort of
realness of the science?
Or how does one know
into these deep topics
if it's real science
or skewed science
or a personal point of view?
CHRIS ANDERSON: I
mean, we're committed
to real science in principle.
What real science is
is a matter of debate,
even among scientists.
We don't have a formal
process for doing it.
We're constantly
thinking about this.
We're actually in the process
of hiring a science curator,
and that person will have a
group of advisors as well.
Certainly,
pseudoscience, I think,
doesn't have a place
on the TED stage.
There's enough amazingness
happening in science.
There are so many
brilliant scientists
out there, who have incredible
knowledge that's worth
sharing without needing to
go to people who are probably
going to end up misleading.
But what the line
is between the two
is sometimes just a
matter of judgment.
JIM LECINSKI: Yeah.
One of my favorite talks
was a young 10-year-old,
I think, that you
had from Africa.
I wonder if you would tell that
story if the audience hasn't
seen his amazing speech.
CHRIS ANDERSON: OK,
so this would be-- I
think it's the Kenyan
boy, Richard Turere.
I think about he might
have been 12 by the time
he got to the TED
stage, but earlier,
he had taught
himself electronics
by taking apart
his parents' radio.
He was a Maasai kid.
He lived in a little
settlement outside Nairobi,
trying to protect
cattle from lions.
And he figured out that moving
lights terrified these lions.
So somehow he built
from parts that he
found a solar powered
light flasher, which
scared away the lions.
And so environmentalists
were happy,
because the villagers
weren't going out and killing
the lions.
And this invention spread
across the area of Kenya,
but when we met this kid
in Nairobi, he was so shy.
He could hardly speak.
You couldn't get the
story out of him.
He was terrified.
And the process of bringing
him to the point where
he got on a plane for the
first time in his life,
came to California,
and somewhere
between Sergey
Brin and Bill Gates
gave a talk about his invention.
And the room just cheered him.
He was so great.
His smile lit up
the entire place,
and he told the
story beautifully.
And it was just about getting
comfortable and rehearsing
and believing in
what he had done.
JIM LECINSKI: And I think
that continually illustrates
the point that it's not
always just the big names
who can deliver a great talk.
The unexpected people are
often the biggest surprises.
CHRIS ANDERSON: Absolutely.
So hi.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious,
how much of the talks
are you recruited
this kid from Kenya,
or how many are supplied to you?
You mentioned you get 10,000
ideas on a yearly basis.
How often are you like, we
need to get this person,
because they have
an idea that we
want to see on the TED stage?
CHRIS ANDERSON: Yeah,
I think it's probably
about 60-40, 60 we recruit
or find or identify, 40.
Most of that 40 come
from people saying,
you know, I saw this
person, and they're amazing.
You must bring them to TED.
And probably 5% of
people who say hey,
I'm ready for the TED stage.
I mean, some of those are
great, but some of those aren't.
And it's something
like that mix.
JIM LECINSKI:
Let's go over here.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much
for being here and sharing
an hour of your day with us.
I love TED.
It's one of my personal goals
to actually watch at least one
or two a week.
I take time out of
my day to do that,
because I find them
to be so valuable.
So I'm curious if you're
able to share any sneak peeks
or what we can expect
this year at TED, or just
some ideas or topics
that might be new
and coming that we can expect.
CHRIS ANDERSON: Well,
next year's TED, the theme
is The Future You.
And so it's going to be more
personal than some TEDs are
with more sort of personal
takeaway of how you can use it.
But it's everything from
the technologies that
are going to be very cool coming
up to literal sort of life
hacks that you can use to
navigate the challenging
world that we're in-- medical
advances and so forth.
So that's the direction.
Our themes are sort of like
a tweak on usual TED content.
It's still from the
same type of palette.
In terms of other talks from
the last TED that are coming up,
well, let's see.
Jennifer Khan's talk on
CRISPR and on gene drives
is coming out soon.
And I think that's incredibly
beautifully explained
and a very powerful
issue that we all
need to be thinking about.
There's a wonderful talk
about misfits coming out.
If you haven't seen it,
do watch the Tim Urban
talk on procrastination.
We all do it.
JIM LECINSKI: I need
to get to that one.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS ANDERSON: Nice.
That was good.
I like that.
Very good.
He procrastinated right up to
the week before the conference,
then realized his talk wasn't
there, flew into this panic,
and ended up coming
up with a masterpiece.
So it was very good.
JIM LECINSKI:
Let's go over here.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to pick on
your media and journalist brain
and ask this question about
the discourse in general
on social media
and news channels.
And it's almost
like the incentives
encourage extremist thinking
and not nuanced thinking.
Like on Twitter because of
word limits, and extreme people
tend to voice their
opinions more.
This is all my personal opinion.
And even for news
channels, like snippets,
and like almost false
news sells more ads.
And these are the
biggest mediums.
I mean it's great to have them
as a medium for communication,
but how do we fix those?
Or like not necessarily
do individual fix, though.
It's like, how do we get
this nuanced discussion out
to everyone?
And TV and social media
are the channels that
reach more than TED, right?
So do you have
thoughts, and have
you thought about this problem?
Or do you feel
this is a problem?
CHRIS ANDERSON: No, it's
definitely a problem.
And I think it's
constantly moving.
I mean, there's many
conversations to be had here.
One of the things I think about,
which I think I'm hopeful at,
is that the world
we're moving to is-- I
think video is going to play
a bigger and bigger role.
If we believe your founders and
people like Zuckerberg and Elon
Musk, we're going
to have low band,
low-cost broadband across every
square inch of the planet.
And I think you can imagine
a future, where people, yes,
they're still looking
down at their screens.
But what they're seeing is
another human face looking back
at them.
And some perforce
when that happens,
some of the traditional
standards and things that
run very deep in how we look and
how we interact with each other
may shift.
There's a bigger premium
on trust and on respect
and so forth.
But I don't know.
I think it's all
to be played for,
and I do think one of the
things that I see some hope in
is that when the battle is
about what will people click on,
that drives a certain
type of behavior.
It drives a kind of extremist,
if you like, to my mind,
lizard brain behavior, where
you go the dramatic and the sort
of whatever.
And that leads to all these
awful sort of Five Celebrity
Sexy Secrets that
duh-duh-duh that are frankly
destroying the internet.
And if you guys could
please Google them out.
But when you go to sharing,
social media sharing,
there, it's more about
someone's identity.
And I think that
triggers a different part
of people's minds.
It's more a reflective choice.
And I think that
type of content,
that's how hopeful stories and
stuff do end up circulating
on social media beautifully.
So it's not an answer
to your question,
but it's a very
long conversation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] enabling
both kinds of behaviors there.
I mean, maybe as
technologists, we
don't think that everything
technology is good,
but perhaps, technology
is also the source
of some of these things.
At least it's enabling
some of these things,
and we maybe should think
about how we fit in.
CHRIS ANDERSON: It is
absolutely possible
that we end up
creating technologies,
where we end up sleepwalking
into a future we don't actually
want.
And you guys, more than
any others in the world,
need to be thinking
about that every day,
because just because
something works in the moment,
and people want
it and like it, it
doesn't mean that
there aren't going
to be terrible, unintended
consequences of it.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so
much for being here.
This is such a fun way
to spend an afternoon.
My question is, I think we all
have stories that we reread
and TED Talks we
revisit to be inspired.
So my question is twofold.
Do you have any
TED talk that you
find yourself rewatching over
and over again that's really
moved you in some way?
And then are there any other
storytellers, maybe even
outside of TED, that
you really admire?
CHRIS ANDERSON: So I'll
answer the first one.
I'm not sure if I've got
a good answer for you
on the second one.
Oh, I do have a good
answer on the second one.
On the first one, there's
a talk by David Deutsch
that I really like.
So he's a physicist.
He's kind of a recluse.
And he gave this talk
basically arguing
that we're not chemical
scum on a random planet
in the universe, as Stephen
Hawking kind of said.
But actually,
knowledge is a force
of potentially universal reach.
And so that is powerful, and
he has this wonderful statement
at the end of it
saying that it's
a kind of a definition
of optimism, I think.
He says, look, carve
two stone tablets.
One of them says,
problems are inevitable.
problems are solvable.
And I think that
what that says is
that not the cliche that
there's a technological solution
to every problem, which I
think really annoys people.
What it says is that
it's right to take
the stance in the world, not
to be beaten by stuff that OK,
there are going to be problems,
that there will always
be problems.
We actually do have a crack
at solving them if we're wise
and if we keep thinking
and keep at it.
So I personally find that a very
nuanced and beautiful message,
and I like that talk.
And on the storyteller, Yuval
Harari's book, "Sapiens,"
is astonishing.
He tells the story
of us as a species,
and he tells it in
extraordinary language
and connects things that you
would never imagine connecting.
And I couldn't recommend
it more strongly.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks for coming.
So in the algorithm,
as you mentioned,
world that we live in, I find
it hard for an individual
to have a sense of
the actual truth
or reality of certain things.
So for example, when I
watch TED Talks on YouTube,
is it over indexed
towards technology,
or is it just, I happen to have
watched several technology TED
Talks, and that's what
YouTube recommends for me?
So my question is just with
your inside perspective,
do you feel that TED is over
indexed in certain areas
or under indexed in others?
And what do you do?
So you just sit back and
let the masses sort of--
CHRIS ANDERSON:
YouTube's algorithm
is entirely to blame here.
YouTube does a brilliant
job of personalizing stuff,
and so what you watch, that's
what it will offer you.
If you were to go to ted.com
and type in the word happiness,
for example, you'd
see a ton of talks
about happiness,
which if anyone is
coming to TED for the first
time, I would say start there.
One, happiness matters.
Two, there's a dozen
different approaches to it
that are different.
And I love those talks.
And the personalization
thing, by the way,
I wish there was a default
setting on YouTube,
where you could say, actually,
I want to be catalyzed.
I don't want you to assume
that I'm only who I click on.
I want to be catalyzed by a
broader sense of knowledge.
Could you do that for me?
And I think a lot of people
would click that setting,
honestly.
JIM LECINSKI: Thank you.
CHRIS ANDERSON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
very much for coming.
I'm sure you've heard
incredible stories from people
all around the world,
communities, groups
of how TED has impacted them.
Do you have a favorite anecdote
or story that you've heard?
CHRIS ANDERSON: There are many.
Many of them just happen
on quite a personal level.
TED moves people from being sort
of skeptical observers to being
engaged agents, and
I love seeing that.
I had one lovely moment
recently at a dinner,
where the waitress serving us
sort of whispered in my ear
that she had watched TED Talks.
And it turned out that I think
she was a Polish immigrant,
and she'd come into the US.
She'd been homeless
for awhile, and her son
had introduced her to TED.
And so it's almost like she
was sort of sneaking hours
in a homeless
shelter for a while
somehow watching TED Talks on
a borrowed iPad or something.
And she was crying,
and so we were crying.
And it was like, I
love the spread of this
that there are so many
people, who want to learn.
I think what she got from that
was a sense of empowerment.
I'm homeless now, but
that's not who I am.
I can be a lot more than that.
And I think there
are a lot of stories
like that at an individual
level that are really
why we do what we do.
JIM LECINSKI: And that brings
us to our final question, which
is the traditional
question we always
ask our guests at these
Authors at Google talks.
Would you be willing to share
with our audience a start,
stop continue, something that
you would suggest that they
start doing, stop
doing, continue
doing to learn and
to be better speakers
and to plant those seeds
of ideas that matter?
CHRIS ANDERSON:
Stop being daunted
by your nervousness about it.
It's there for a reason.
It's there to motivate
you to put the work in
to produce a great talk.
Start speaking up.
Everyone needs to.
The world's too complicated
for single experts
to solve these problems.
It needs lots of
us to participate.
Please be part of that.
Continue.
Well, first of all, continue
doing what you're doing.
This is one of the
world's great companies,
and you're empowering,
literally now,
billions of people
around the world
to find knowledge more quickly.
I mean, it's absolutely
incredible what
has been created in
this organization.
So keep doing that.
Continue being not evil.
It's hard, actually, when
you're a big public company.
And stay curious.
That's the single biggest thing.
I passionately believe
in the power of curiosity
to lead to things
that are special.
I mean, the more you
know, the more interesting
the world gets.
So stay curious.
JIM LECINSKI: Chris, thank
you for the gift of TED,
and thank you for being
with us here today.
CHRIS ANDERSON:
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]